Ukrainian forces say they've repelled
multiple assaults on the town of volidar
south of the besides city of bakmut and
claimed to have destroyed more than 100
armored fighting Vehicles near there in
the past week wiping out potentially
hundreds of Russian soldiers but Russia
says it is continuing to take territory
in the East albeit one small piece at a
time and ukrainians have been killed by
the Dozen the ground reality in this war
of attrition depends on who you ask
the Eastern front line is more than a
thousand kilometers long fighting too
small to register may not make headlines
but even the smallest Skirmish seen
Through The Eyes of one family
can become the greatest of tragedies
evacuating from voladar the agony of one
family's decision to abandon their home
outweighed only by the pain of knowing
they waited too long
The Strain perhaps too great for one
grandmother her heart stopped moments
before reaching safety
relief at being out of danger
replaced by the grief of loss
we have to convince the people for an
hour or two sometimes then your
relatives persuade them we talk to them
the police talk to them the military
Administration says you have to evacuate
but that doesn't convince them for some
reason
Ukrainian positions in volodar have held
since the start of the war but Russians
outnumber ukrainians on the front line
and are making gains North
foreign
This Is Our Land this is our home our
relatives our families our cities are
behind us
those living in the war zone experience
freezing temperatures and a lack of food
electricity and water
God forbid our forces from retreating
and leaving us Behind Enemy Lines God
forbid I will not survive this again
those who have watched loved ones die
their homes destroyed and are still here
say this should not be happening in the
21st century
will the latest offensive get worse can
their military hold out against
overwhelming odds will there be more
missile strikes will more Western help
get here in time days before a milestone
this country was hoping to avoid a year
of war with Russia ukrainians are
seeking answers to tough questions one
thing has remained constant throughout
this conflict where Russia and Ukraine
meet on the battlefield civilian
suffering soon follows Zane vasravi Al
Jazeera Kiev